[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the financial times whitehall
editor sebastian payne and the
spectators economics correspondent kate
andrews
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the granddad of
six-year-old arthur la binjo hughes is
on the front of the sun saying his
grandson's killers must never be freed
the telegraph reports that nearly
two-thirds of house-bound people have
yet to receive their coveted booster
after many gps opted out of delivering
top-up jabs
a vaccine creator is warning the
coronavirus pandemic is far from over
and the next one that follows could be
even more lethal that's the front of the
guardian
the mirror says fears are growing that
christmas celebrations could trigger a
surge in coronavirus cases and lead to
restrictions in the new year
the financial times leads with the chief
executive of lloyd's banking group
preparing a strategy that would include
expanding its ambitions in property
snow wind and heavy rain is coming to
batter britain storm barra is set to
bring more power and travel chaos before
christmas says the metro
the express says certain eu rules are
set to be axed which will give smaller
uk companies a better chance of winning
multi-million pound contracts
and the mail has a royal story on its
front claiming prince harry raised
concerns about the donor in the cash for
access scandal
joining me tonight sebastian payne and
kate andrews welcome to you both good
evening let's start with the mirror and
a suggestion
here if you look at the headline that
christmas could be our undoing according
to uh to an expert
kate
so in a few weeks time the prime
minister is set to lay out what
christmas day will look like of course
for now in the christmas season and
it seems very different uh to how it was
last year uh the uk on on most accounts
is more or less free to go about as
business people can more or less do what
they want with you know some very key
mass mandates and also some new
quarantine mandates around the new
variant
the suggestion here though is is that um
a free christmas might lead to uh more
restrictions perhaps even a lockdown in
january now that we know for political
reasons that the government really wants
christmas to go ahead as normal but i
think what's being overlooked here are
the politics and also the numbers when
it comes to covet right now we know this
virus can always surprise us but from a
political angle i think even return
restrictions and certainly lockdown in
january would be very difficult for this
government it's not at all obvious that
boris johnson's own backbench mps would
necessarily go along with it
also when we look at the numbers again
we know things could change but right
now cova patients occupy roughly five
percent
of hospital beds we're 83 below the peak
of where we were when things were at
their worst in the health service this
does raise questions really as as to
what's going wrong here of course
everybody should be encouraged to get
their jabs we want as few people in
hospital as possible but arguably there
is capacity in the health service so why
we're we're all of a sudden saying
they're going to be restrictions in
january if things aren't tamed now i do
think should be challenged slightly
um and sebastian do you think we we
might see um restrictions brought in
we christmas i mean we're very close to
it now but but to prevent the the
ultimate which could possibly be a
lockdown in january
look i don't think we're anywhere near
that and we've got to be very well we're
in such a different place from where we
were before with coronavirus because of
the vaccines you know this time last
year the aza jab was on the cusp of
being approved it was still months
before we got the first shot into
people's arms so i think it's very clear
that the reason we had lockdown was
because there was no reason no and way
of controlling um infections whereas we
do have that now we also have many
better medications anti-viral pills and
the like with more coming online every
week that help us combat that so i think
we've got to be careful about not
getting carried away here about lockdown
and of course there's a heavy economic
and health cost that comes with lockdown
as well within terms of the wider
economy so i think the question is we
should look at christmas it's going to
depend what we find out about their
omicron variant and we read it in the
weekend papers that around the 17th of
december boris johnson will have a
pretty clear view from the port and down
laboratories what this new variant is
and there's two key things to look out
for one is it more transmissible and two
does it cause more serious illness now
all the data we have so far is very
patchy and incomplete there are some
signs it may be more transmissible but
there is nothing in terms of serious
illness so i think until you get that
you can't really speculate about what
measures may or may not be needed but i
think fundamentally kate is right
there's no appetite in the conservative
party or in the government to go back
into further measures which come with a
big economic cost and a health cost to
the wider economy um and second of all
and i think boys johnson very much wants
people to have a good christmas you know
if you look at what happened last year
and people feel a big sense of deja vu
when we had the alpha variant that
emerged and disrupted all of our plans
but i think i imagine christmas will go
ahead pretty much as we would expect it
to normally there may be for example
more stringent mask wearing rules there
may be an older
but aside from that i don't really think
this side of christmas things are going
to change that significantly
let's uh go back to last christmas uh
still being discussed in the context of
a um
basha christmas bash that was held um
allegedly and also a leaving do boris
johnson is supposed to have held
what is dominic raab saying about
possible investigations into this kate
this is uh the metro
well he dismissed it this morning saying
that there was no probable cause to go
back a year and look into whether or not
the prime minister and potentially other
people at the heart of government were
breaking lockdown rules now i'm always
skeptical when we actively try to bring
the police into allegations
against anybody breaking lockdown rules
because so often when people have been
accused of it the police get it wrong
but there is a much broader question
that i think the prime minister has to
answer here um and it's an
accountability issue when you are the
person who is making the rules you must
not be the person who is also breaking
the rules now downing street is
insistent that the prime minister and
whoever else was potentially attending
an event that they haven't actually said
didn't take place they've said that at
any time the rules were being followed
but we know throughout the summer uh
also through revelations about who was
in downing street on christmas day last
year that the people making the rules
could often find loopholes or they were
able to get around it more easily
whether this was ministers traveling
abroad for work that was clearly not
urgent and not having to quarantine upon
return because the rules were written in
the government's favor whether it was
special events when we were coming out
of covid that just happened to line up
with the westminster's westminster's
best events and the hottest items in the
westminster calendar that ministers were
attending we know that they have
loopholes and and it's not in the spirit
of what the public was asked to do last
year and for a huge chunk of this year
it's not in the spirit of of staying
home and keeping safe the fact that the
story continues to rumble on suggests to
me that well we may never really get
answers people will continue to ask
questions of the prime minister and his
team because it does doesn't sit right
that even if it was technically legal
people would be having drinks and
enjoying themselves in a way that the
public was expressively told not to yes
and on that note uh that the metro
quotes campaigners from covet 19
bereaved families for justice who said
that they're sickened by the prospect of
the government hosting parties while
thousands were dying and millions of
families were separated at christmas
sebastian
indeed and you can understand the anger
about this if we recall the barnard
castle incident where dominic cummings
who was then boyce johnson's chief
adviser broke covert rules by driving
across the country that created huge
outrage because it gave that sense it's
one rule for them and one rule for the
rest of us and that's a very similar
thing with this particular story here
and so far all number ten has said is it
doesn't recognize the accounts it says
rules were followed at all time but it
won't engage in any of the details about
this and you know there is al the met
have said they're not going to
investigate this today they haven't
actually done that much investigating a
retrospective breaking of the coveted
regulations here but you know i think
there is one clear thing that i saw in
my day job as a political journalist is
that people in westminster had a very
different covert experience of a lot of
the country because many of them were
continuing to go into the office because
they had to for work for policy reasons
and although there was obviously a lot
of working from home like the rest of
the country but it was certainly a
bubble compared to how say the city of
london or other cities or manual sectors
working throughout the pandemic and that
in itself had a stunting effect on
policy making and i think some critics
might say that the government was more
eager to go into lockdown because it
didn't necessarily have the same effect
on very senior parts of the government
or senior elements of the civil service
and i think we look at this number 10
party that might speak to that
particular kind of thing there but you
know ultimately is this going to be
damaging for the government and i think
it does planes that narrative that labor
has tried to put across by saying you
know they say one thing do another
they're not on your side and
particularly for those parts of the
country that voted tory for the first
time in 2019 boris johnson tried to
paint himself a different kind of
conservative leader a bit more popular
shall we say someone who's on the side
of the people has often used the term
the people's government when they see
stories like this it's same with
politicians same old toys and that's why
the government is just not engaging this
and hoping the story will shut up and go
away but it's actually now crime week
for boris johnson there's a whole wave
of announcements coming over the next
couple of days and i imagine a lot of
people will be saying well hang on a
minute you're talking about getting
tough on the courses of crime what about
potential breaking the culvert rules in
your very own building
okay let's move on to the telegraph um
and the government eager to get people
to take up their their booster jabs but
they're 300 000 housebound people who
seemingly have been neglected
yeah this is a startling number on the
front page of the telegraph uh tomorrow
it suggests that roughly only a fourth
of people who
are housebound who need their booster in
order to keep them as safe as possible
as kovit continues to be a part of our
lives um have actually been able to
receive their booster job and the
telegraph is saying that a lot of this
comes down to the fact that gps have
opted out of of the home delivery
service to deliver boosters and then of
course there's the knock-on effect that
um many gps aren't wanting to be back in
the office either which is really limits
the number of people who can quite
crudely get jabs into arms through the
gp service now we saw that the national
rollout of the vaccine at the start of
the year was hugely successful in part
because you almost had that military
style of mass vaccination centers just
shuffling people through to get their
jabs but if we are going to learn to
live with the virus and it's going to
become like getting your flu jab as well
as your covet booster then that is
there's going to be a crucial role for
gps in that it has to be more
sustainable system which clearly we
don't have yet there's going to be a
blame game is this the government's
fault is this an issue of resources is
this the gp's fault the nhs is full that
there aren't enough people to deliver
these jobs but the bottom line here is
that there are an estimated 300 000
vulnerable people who are homebound who
haven't had their booster yet and as seb
suggested at the beginning of this
segment you know the vaccines are the
huge game changer that we have now they
are the solution to the kova crisis and
we just have to be delivering those
booster jobs to the people who need it
sebastian we're running out of time but
uh quickly come in on this
yes and i think look the fact is there's
still about a good ten percent of the
country that hasn't had its first or
second jobs of cobalt vaccines and that
is going to become so crucial to try and
make sure we can get through the winter
without a big problem for the nhs and
trying to track down that final 10 and
persuade them i think is really
important as well of course as that
booster program
sebastian and kate thank you very much
for the moment coming up plans to seize
the passports of middle-class drug users
that's on the front of the guardian
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me the financial
times is whitehall leaders sebastian
payne and the spectators economics
correspondent kate andrews let's um have
a look at the sun um and the headline
speaks for itself there can't be a
person around who doesn't know what this
is in reference to um the very
distressing story the murder of arthur
the bingo hughes kate
yes uh
i think now that we've had um you know
the the tragic updates about what
happened to this poor little boy people
are obviously asking how this could have
happened and arthur's grandfather's is
calling for an inquiry and the
government is planning on an inquiry
which is going to include looking at a
sentence review for for how long
arthur's murderers in particular will be
behind bars but how long anybody should
be behind bars i think part of this
comprehensive review we have to look at
sentencing but we also have to look at
how the authorities got this so badly
wrong given the evidence we have now
that they were alerted to the the
dangers and the abuse taking place
in that home and how this was allowed to
continue and also the safeguarding that
we have for children that exist outside
of the home obviously with lockdown um
any attention that arthur might have had
from other grown-ups was extremely
limited and that makes the situation
even more difficult but it has to be
holistic because we have to do
everything we possibly can to make sure
an instant and a tragic incident like
this is never repeated yes and sebastian
we know as uh kate is saying there that
the government are launching a review
but we have been here before
with cases such as victoria columbia
baby p and we've had reviews before what
is going to be different this time
well i think obviously this is coming
from the very top this is the prime
minister has called for this and sue
ella braverman the attorney general as
well so
in terms of this whole case but also the
particular sentencing i think you know
everyone has been shocked by just the
[ __ ] depravity of what you've seen of
how arthur was treated and of course as
you mentioned there's many instances the
baby pee one comes to mind a lot as well
about how this was not seen by the
various levels of authority and i think
as we found in that instance there was a
systemic problem in terms of child
protection and services available now
there's been a lot of questions here
about whether lockdown played a role
this because obviously people were home
a lot more and did that included i'm
sure that's going to be past the review
but i think as has been noted how did
teachers have rather not noticed that
you know he was being uh mistreated he
wasn't being fed proper he was being
treated so badly at home here so i think
that's the questions you have to look
into that at school and in the community
there should be people who have spotted
this why did they and if they did did
they report it and did they have the
mechanisms to do something about it
because that's how i have to make sure
this thing doesn't happen again i think
with the sentencing as well you know i
think um his stepmom's got his 29 years
with um with before potential parole but
i think people wanted something much
stronger because it's totally sickening
and it reads the gut of your stomach
when you read the reports here and it
just
it's beyond comprehension how humans
could behave like this but we also have
to make sure the system is in place to
cope with even people who give those
disgusting treatment yes
okay take us to the guardian um the
story about how to deal with wealthier
drug users um suggestions from boris
johnson as to sanctions they may face in
future
so as part of the government's crime
week in which they want to show that
this conservative government will crack
down on crime will go hard on crime it
looks like their first big announcement
or one of their first big announcements
will be around
middle-class drug users and they're
trying to suggest here
that um you won't just be facing fines
uh if you are um using drugs uh and
purchasing class a drugs you could be
facing far more serious consequences
including losing your driver's license
and losing your passport i mean look
when i read a story like this you know
i'm skeptical as to how this might
actually hold up if a person were to
challenge this um in the court of law
whether or not um such an authoritarian
measure is taking somebody's passport
away really would hold up to me this
crackdown only suggests that the entire
system as it relates to drugs in this
country is just still completely wrong
and there's so much exploitation so much
exploitation that comes from the current
system but unfortunately this crackdown
is unlikely to end it um to actually cut
out those who are exploited whether
they're in the uk or they're in a
developing country usually comes through
the legalizing process and it's not
being considered here